FIRST, NOT AN OBAMA REPEAT.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
BERNIE SANDERS CANNOT GET A
BREAK.
AFTER 2016, WHEN HE WAS
ESSENTIALLY HOSED BY THE DNC AND
DISMISSED BY THE MEDIA, THIS WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE HIS TIME.
THEN IN IOWA, DESPITE GETTING
THE MOST VOTES, HE ENDED UP WITH
FEWER DELEGATES THAN
PETE BUTTIGIEG, GIVING THE
FORMER MAYOR A ROSY PRESS
NARRATIVE GOING INTO
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
BUT EVEN WHEN BERNIE PULLED OUT
A CLEAR VICTORY IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, IT IS STILL NOT
EVEN TREATED LIKE A WIN.
SPEAK OF THE BIG WINNER LAST
NIGHT COULD BE MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
>> BUTTIGIEG, KLOBUCHAR AND
BIDEN SPLIT THE MODERATE VOTE
WITH THEIR COMBINED PERCENTAGE
WINNING OVER SANDERS.
>> TWO MONITOR IT CANDIDATES
COME AT A VERY STRONG SHAPE
TONIGHT.
>> Laura: AGAIN, THEY WILL
SUPPORT EVERYBODY EXCEPT THE GUY
WHO ACTUALLY WON.
BUT THE REASON IS OBVIOUS BY THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE ELITES
DON’T WANT THE CURMUDGEON
SOCIALIST BERNIE SANDERS TO RUN
AWAY WITH THE NOMINATION BECAUSE
WHAT WOULD THAT DUKE WAS MIKE
THAT WOULD UPEND THEIR COMFY IF
INEFFECTIVE STATUS QUO.
NOW JOE BIDEN WAS SUPPOSED TO
STOP HIM BUT WE NEED TO STOP HIM
FROM EMBARRASSING HIMSELF.
CALLED THE CAREGIVER APPEARED
THE MAN SHOULD BE DOING SOME
AGE-APPROPRIATE ACTIVITIES THAT
WILL KEEP HIS MIND ACTIVE, BUT
CAMPAIGNING SHOULDN’T BE ONE OF
THEM FOR POOR OLD BIDEN.
GIVEN ALL THIS, WHERE ARE THE
MEDIA TOADIES GOING TO TURN TO
NOW?
TO THE PERSON WHOM I DABBED LAST
WINTER AS THE LEFT’S NEW IT BOY.
THE NEWEST DARLING OF
JOURNALISTS, HOLLY WATERS AND
METRO LEFTIES
IS THE MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND,
INDIANA, THE COASTAL ELITES?
I DON’T THINK THEY’VE EVER LOVED
A MIDWESTERNER AS MUCH AS THEY
LOVE PETE.
HE IS A CHARMER.
>> Laura: HE LOOKED DASHING IN
HIS ARMY FATIGUES TOO.
A POLICY WALK, A HARVARD GUY,
ROSE SCHOLAR, YET HE IS VERY
MODEST.
HE IS A MODERN-DAY RENAISSANCE
MAN.
>> GOD BLESS PETE BUTTIGIEG BUT
HE KINDS OF TALKS OF THE LEVEL
OF MR. ROGERS.
THE COMPOSURE AND POISE AND HE
JUST DID IT UP HERE ON THE STAGE
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
HE SPEAKS AND SENTENCES.
IT’S AMAZING, HE’S AN AMAZING
HUMAN BEING.
>> Laura: DOESN’T PETE JUST
MAKE YOU ALL FEEL INADEQUATE?
AND THERE IS MORE.
PETE EVOLVED TOO APPEAR ALSO.
>> TALKING ABOUT GROWING AS A
CANDIDATE, MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND,
INDIANA, AND NOW HE IS THE COLD
FRONT RUNNER PERHAPS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
>> Laura: COMPANY FRONT RUNNER
PLUS MARK IS THAT WHAT THEY
SAID?
I GUESS TECHNICALLY MAYBE YOU
COULD SAY THAT BUT HE IS PULLING
13 POINTS BEHIND BERNIE SANDERS
NATIONALLY, NOT TO MENTION IN
THE NEXT TWO NOMINATION
CONTESTS, HE IS AT 7% AND 5.5%
RESPECTIVELY.
WE NEEDED TO GET THE .5% IN PEER
BUT WHAT HE LACKS POPULARLY ON
MAIN STREET, HE MAKES UP FOR
THAT MORE THAN THAT ON
WALL STREET.
LET’S FACE IT, THEY WANT TO
HEDGE AGAINST BERNIE.
AND THEY KNOW PETE WILL BE PUTTY
IN THE HANDS OF SOMEONE LIKE
PRESIDENT XI AND THAT IS GOOD
FOR THE GLOBALISTS.
AT FIRST GLANCE, BUTTIGIEG SEEMS
TO HAVE A REALLY GOOD POLITICAL
RESUME.
FORMER SMALL-TOWN MAYOR, ARMY
RESERVIST, RHODES SCHOLAR.
IN THE FIRST GAY PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
BUT WHILE HE MAY BE A FIRST LIKE
OBAMA, OBAMA HAD BOTH CHARISMA
AND AT LEAST HE HAD BEEN A
SENATOR.
BUTTIGIEG REALLY IS KIND OF A
BLAND COMPOSITE OF A LOT OF
THINGS BUT WITH ZERO RELEVANT
EXPERIENCE.
THE ONLY THING HE HAS EVER RUN,
SOUTH BEND, INDIANA, IS A
CRIME-RIDDEN MESS.
VIOLENT CRIME SURGED 70% DURING
HIS TIME AS MAYOR WHILE THE
COUNTRY AS A WHOLE SAW CRIME
FALL BY 2% IN THAT SAME
TIME FRAME.
BUT PAY NO ATTENTION TO THE
FACTS, JUST KEEP HINTING THAT HE
IS LIKE OBAMA, EXCEPT GAY AND
WHITE.
>> THERE’S NO QUESTION AT ALL
THAT PETE BUTTIGIEG IS OCCUPYING
A BIT OF THAT OBAMA LANE.
>> REMINDS ME A LITTLE BIT OF
EARLY OBAMA IN THE CAMPAIGN.
>> BARACK OBAMA BEFORE HIM,
PETE IS YOUNG, HE IS
INSPIRING, HE BRINGS FRESH IDEAS
TO THE TABLE.
>> Laura: UNLIKE OBAMA, WHO
CAN INSPIRE HIS SUPPORTERS WITH
A SOARING RHETORIC.
REMEMBER THAT 2004 DNC SPEECH
AND GRAND IDEALISM?
WHEN BUTTIGIEG TRIES TO MAKE
PROFOUND STATEMENTS COME HE JUST
ENDS UP SOUNDING LIKE AN IDIOT.
>> IT IS TIME TO WALK AWAY FROM
THE POLITICS OF THE PAST AND
TOWARDS SOMETHING TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
BY THIS TIME, IT’S NOT JUST
ABOUT WINNING AN ELECTION, IT’S
ABOUT WINNING AN ERA.
SPEAK OF THE SHAPE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IS THE ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS EVERY OTHER ISSUE.
>> TAKING OUT A BAD GUY IS NOT A
GOOD IDEA IF YOU DO NOT KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
>> Laura: WOW, D.
FOR SELF ABSORBED LIBERALS,
BUTTIGIEG IS KIND OF LIKE AN INK
SPLOTCH.
HE IS A RORSCHACH TEST.
THEY READ INTO HIM WHAT THEY
WANT TO SEE, EVEN IF IT IS NOT
THERE.
THERE SEETHING HATRED OF ALL
THINGS TRUMP HAS EARNED
OTHERWISE REASONABLY INTELLIGENT
DEMOCRATS INTO PUDDLES OF GOO,
LOOKING FOR THEIR NEXT CRASH.
BUT LIKE ALL SHALLOW CRASHES,
THIS ONE TOO WILL END UP